look I don't want to lecture to you guys
alright I'm not gonna lecture at you
guys I just want to listen to myself
lecture with you guys you see we don't
need more gun control this country
already has a way we deal with gun
violence shootings happen thoughts and
prayers we buy more guns problem solved
but you gen Z post millennial emoji
stalkers are trying to mess all this up
so you hear this you've heard it from my
friends on the right the alex jones the
laura ingraham the tucker carlson you
know their names you probably have their
posters up in your rooms they say that
you're being manipulated by the press
that you don't understand what you're
talking about but let me ask you do you
really I mean really do you want a ban
on assault rifles that's what you really
want yeah is that really what you
actually want okay I'm I'm sure there's
another team out there who who agrees
with me there is I know that I'm just a
typical teen hanging with my squad and
this mister Keppler guy definitely seems
like a thirsty old dork who dresses like
an assistant principal but I don't know
some of his ideas seem pretty Gucci
Thanks average teenager are you going to
the March no way that's so not Gucci I'm
gonna Lloyd her by the vape store and
work on my promposal sounds pretty lit
now the rest of you kids don't know what
you're talking about
you stole the keys to America and you're
taking her for a joyride
that's why the opposition is here all
weekend our citizen journalists are
stationed throughout the house to
chaperone the movement and keep six
inches between you and real change
Laura gray what are you seeing I'm
chaperoning the signs Jordan I'm here in
the teenage Ministry of propaganda aka
this rec room or whatever it is where
the kids are making signs like hashtag
never again and ban assault weapons now
well guess what I am filtrated with some
adult signs of my own guns are people
too just kidding right cuz JK you guys
right Thank You Laura Nicole Thurmond is
upstairs what's going on to call Jordan
these kids are so energetic I just want
to support them so I brought them
shop position brand gift bags for the
March on Saturday it's got everything
it's got mats it's got granola waters
some military-grade horse tranquilizers
they're gonna kick in about right when
the March is starting tell you what they
gonna love it
better safe than sorry listen up
opposers homes like this are the most
dangerous places in the country because
they're full of ideas and ideas are
dangerous if an idea ends up in the
wrong hands it can really hurt someone
so kids maybe step back and leave the
change to us adults because we're the
best and making sure nothing happens to
it
[Music]